This
is the carol in each American English dialect recordings collection produced
with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the Center for
Applied Linguistics. This is tape number forty five
psi a.
Drinking
devils when they get crazy and me lose their mind and.
One Sunday he had said he's looking from the window and he broke the window right this
is the East and he said his face coming after
me broke to win because that's all that
that's what. Some of that when I said the alcoholic.
Yeah. So some of that when I grew up it kept me going. Yeah.
I never know where he went or what happened to him or anything more
because I can't even think of his I think that first name was Jack.
But whatever his last name I can't remember anymore. There are so many men
each can fall most at different men but there are
all Finnish fellas
anyway. And if they do see a sound
thing that one set that.
Keep your march clothes store was out and that was it they had to
be quiet so they didn't when they were working and they were working but
it was so Sunday or something when he got wild
that. One time I
went. Let's go I know it's there.
My house and we don't.
My baby with us and just that Sunday when we come back.
All
I asked lemon extract for the like when you
make a can of any luck. All that was gone.
They had to test for
all of it they were sick so sick that there has been.
Yeah. So I know what they
do. What with liberty.
Now were
you I was traced into the valley that fast. We
had and I rented out some and then we bought our
own place. We want to go. Yeah I was born
there and. Your father speech was pregnant with your father.
Yeah yeah. Come over.
Yes he came home he came
over and nineteen.
Eighty you know. Eighty and it's
me. In nine T..
I believe it was I'm not sure of a friendly exhaust there
were from your your mothers and I know she was she
talked it was so little that there wasn't much that. I don't know if mother
know how to
talk there so he said all but my grandmother did mother's mother. Yeah.
You knew with the.
You know it's.
Your
father God was right what were you. Yeah that's a T. that
lumbering business with us.
It was his business.
Wouldn't you love it. My mother was just home
and. The children
and. Farm Collison stuff like
that that used to call when we were close or he used to call home every weekend but.
Then or too far well then he
wouldn't. It
wouldn't work
yeah yeah. Yeah.
And then when the children cruel. Then I started crying and they
were all
gone then I started. Being and then and I
went and did.
Resort cooking for quite a few
years or so and tried in a
hotel some tried in the restaurants
and
I was cooking to our son in
the war for no good for. No not
at all I don't know if our so called but I went by with that
anyway. You know that was as far as working
in particular.
Now that wasn't always easy but when you if you are still at
it const naturally to you it isn't so
that. I can do more
than
thirty. What did you do.
My husband was a mechanic except when we were in one camp Well then
he helped with
the. Men in the it's and. And
then one one camp that my father had little sound mail and they
thought that ice. Then one that was getting closer and he brought a
little sawmill and they thought that I didn't need them on ready
but I saw
now that was reluctant yes
almost
no.
And producers to how capable those men are We had one. They used to call
him
Big Sam or would leg it because he
had lost his one leg railroad
accident. And he was a big
man already an alder
man and you know how they get on now when four of
those trees. And I went. We didn't have many
men more so I had lost the time to watch it walk when they were close to
the camp and watch him follow those trees
and I watched him and cut that granted.
So I he stood with that he made his own lake. He
never bought ID Fishel he made his own from a piece of
wood and hitched a hitch the wires and everything and and nothing
else around no
waste and a strap around here and he always the men said that
when he went to bed he took it off and laid it down beside him he always sleep the
lot. But he stuck to it that. Thekla lake.
On top of that tree just not like the rest of them.
He was he was a man for the cleanest man he think
when he was drinking
but he never hurt anybody by talking or
he was always soul needs otherwise talked so clean. You wouldn't
have to be afraid of him
or ever think anything about it you know the real Chantel
but sometimes you were kind or leery about some of them
because you'll never know where they are. He was always he was
around sitter Valley for all years and years and years
and.
To. I
mean my if that's that
then let's have one to hand.
He killed another hack my.
Oh. Then I'd like to call it.
Yes.
Yeah I'm just getting so interesting like the view Rather reporting.
Oh you are with this project before or
whatever so I keep to you empty all your picture you in the eye and
interested in the influences of
things on the front where you work a lot with the over there I suppose I don't know
but we don't we're in different the part. I see. Oh I guess he's coming in our department. Yeah.
Obviously he's just any Maybe living geography going in the college
off years.
So you don't speak Spanish to me. Yes Well we make
an interview you do that. Well that's very good for
me but I thought yeah I'll
have you know
if you want that but I don't want to disrupt because this
is Iran tech I am going to go in take
that. Let me do that tomorrow. OK And then you know then.
We're going to chance to. You know exactly what you want it oh OK
OK thirty. So I get done with that point and I'll come back. OK
OK up in Home and Away. OK the rear are suckers
for no more than all the knob doing
all this is what you're doing is more important because I was here tomorrow. You know I just have coffee and I
have for the we have got a project that's halfway done over there
that I am putting to adopt ten
or so hours going
fishing and all we've got a place at the lake that. We plan
to build for an eventual permanent hole
and that's what I just. Just go to go. There's so
many things you're actively involved in where so that.
When you're in pain and then I'm going
fishing. Yeah you sure
me tactiles house is available and but
the only one we told if you
want to see these folks to bring them all be on
the stage but that would not interfere they could stay there.
I think they do just fine
but that's not possible. How long have you been with
your
George
Dance.
Well I think this is season one. I know one of the
Argos several mean yeah right.
I see George teaches in the. Know it's
a use that you indeed teaches in the
geology here. I'm not I think it's a burn.
All right Bruce is a woman. OK.
Bruce stayed on that T.V. season he did teach the no.
No coaches but he sees
no work for Judge will. Some new
ones or of course
all the wonders of probation.
Right
OK. I know I met him some of it's a good
friend all I see. Yeah OK
yeah yeah there's several of these objects in fact. All but for
me right. Yeah. Who says extended He just had the same.
Three girls and boys.
Just help myself yeah
how can we strengthen were true.
Yeah OK. You know when you grew up in.
Into your analogy to the valley. You
know we
were yeah you know we had a little farm far own.
With into too much farming though. Now I know the sun has the
farm all over and he's made a way out there and I don't think
you know what he had last year he had some knowledge there but the beret last is
also very.
Well what was it like when you grew up there. It did what kind of how did your day start the start of the
chores and things.
You know we can get up early before you went to school but yeah like Oh when we were
at that home and went to school yeah you had to get up and so we
are buying chores and feed the cattle and so
on the new head of the school and sometimes when you
came home from school to to
your lunch home but then you had to get
some hit
some hay for the house and then get ready in that hour
and go back to school we weren't too far from the school
about but would it be about half a mile from here.
And then get back to the classes and same thing when you come back home
can show close
and. Get Your than.
Wired to fall. Take care. Well what sort of things.
Did you do for recreation. What kind of games did you play
for the last couple out the son of. Another a
vast one. They could get as good and there wasn't too much.
There was something that they used to call summer time but
winter time we used to have skinny and there was a little hill there but we did. If
we went with the skis to school. Well we piled two three pair of
skis together and then all piled on the ski sent just went down the
hill. And there were none would since some of
the boys made a lot calls in the water a little cabin and
all that. There wasn't really much to
do and they had a little skating on there but that
wasn't much of a foot
to reduce them though
I did and I fell down and I hurt my head the first time about the skates
on and
that's that's the end of my skating work they were there with
those clamp on things you have to plan for and when you were those the lumberjack
around robbers for the skates didn't stay good on those
gun but we got them from our teacher for Christmas fresh and I am
a sister and they just want to stay on the right way.
I mean yeah. Yeah.
You said you played cricket. Ticket to get test get over you
played well
you go in a circle and then one course around and they're saying and.
Then the one that has a handkerchief or a stick or something and you just go around
and trot that and if he notices for he or you
put it down you have to run and catch the one
that Ruster And if you get attacked Well then you have to
change or
yeah every original Down was.
Co-opted by law I don't know how you explain that but that was not that most of us.
You played a brawl. You had your homes and your sticks and you
were here and
here. And it's four or five and you had
your whole in here and then the middle one north with the ball and you try to
hit with the wrong. Throw hit it so it would hit somebody and when
you hear step on the new to the whole if you hear that and then that one had to
be in the center
and hit. Oh
yeah yeah.
Too much you
really can't think of
anything fast like.
Alaska loaned to us.
Glasgow. While couples. Couples on how
many couples you want like this one in the front here and around
they holler last couple out what this go around like this and this he's
this one here. That's a single one tries to
catch one of them. So the one that's left without the prior
sheet of these one and that one that catches Well they will be in the front and then.
The one that was left along with it then that'll call and then this last one world
for good or circles around
like everybody could Yeah and that's sort of like.
Yeah. You know. You mentioned it used to go to dances.
Did you go in the days when you were in the
bar you know that's how I want to know we said I want
to feel transitory rock wintertime because it was too far to
go around that in the winter time with the girl. We hired
on bass who of us or something and gone to the swamp with
a shorter.
And that. Twenty
times and about our on the road.
It was so far too well and there was not a highly and of course at that time the kids didn't have
cars at
all so and they came with the horses too and usually their
horses were
in father's Harned same with
the Elmer when there was
a team of horses and they canceled there was quite a few when the one played and
the with a kid. Yeah well how would the most
British people
mostly Finnish evil there are still floodlit hat he'll enlist people
that came voice from there but not too many most of
them
are. But teacher he was too cool and
oh yeah. These were allowed to go to yeah that was the only entertainment there was.
And the things they had just mark and concern. Well in stockings
and winter
time. Oh
yeah OK yeah. So with this some of this. This is what you have to fight.
Yeah.
Is that revenge or.
No when I was in no way but I ruined we didn't live too
far
away each other how did you reach your house.
I guess it's nice to I have to say to us that
then us.
But when one quest A was to visit my folks and
so
on did you. Where did you know you were going. This was going
to be the man.
Well my sister went with him first.
Not this one not my other this with us. Yeah my wrist.
And I don't know how it. How it got then twisted in and
then. And she got a letter and she hit
the letters some ways. I don't know why I didn't know I
still don't know what was
in the letter.
But then at the next stand he
said now walking home is your I'm all home with you
so that's how it started just like just like that when he came
to work for
dad then he worked every winter and then just going with
the mare. What were you married. We were
just married at home all privately. No company. No
nothing
to me to stay overnight at our place because that's
really there was only they had to take that and then
Mr down to well we you know to catch the train to call the plough
Kay because that's where they came once a month. So he stayed overnight so
he
just marriages and.
So I've been there twice really fast away and we were
married thirty three years with him and your children are all sent up.
And then I was
a widow for eight years. And then
there is the Irishman very swift. Yeah. And he had
been Hudler for eight years himself he lost his weight
that that.
About the same time as I lost my but I didn't know him at that
time but I wanted for his sister here cooked in his
sister shop. And he used to come and visit a sister and that's how I met him.
And then I worked at Chick walk. You know where that is confluent
trail down and grammar a while we're there.
Yeah and
I that's how I met
him.